i wasn't even allowed to go to my
[ __ ] local high school what high
school did you go i went to frank
sinatra school of arts is that the one
where the guys suck each other's [ __ ]
along
i think that's the one
[Laughter]
frank sinatra that's a rat pack son
don't disrespect that's true but frank
didn't go there tony bennett used to
walk around my school he founded it
really yeah
kevin spacey spoke at my high school
graduation no jesus christ did he try
you no
is that a little demoralizing i do i
i wasn't a good looking kid
you grew up i had the same size head
since like the fifth grade bro oh yeah i
grew into it finally so you just look
like tyrion lannister
absolutely like a goose
and then so kevin's face is there what
did he tell you guys he was actually
funny he was he was he like he did the
speech and it was great yeah seinfeld
spoke at our first graduation no yeah
the king of new york
first graduation he spoke at he's got a
only new yorker murdered murdered then i
meet him right and i told essie i was
like he spoke at my high school's first
graduation she's like come with me i'm
like half drunk oh no i walk up to
seinfeld i'm like you spoke at my high
school graduation you know at my
school's high school graduation goes
frank sinatra school of arts i go yeah
how do you remember that he goes oh you
think i speak out a lot of high schools
because when tony bennett calls you show
off
good stuff
i've heard the terrible ones so i'm
having mine's great yeah i was ready for
you to convince these guys that he's a
[ __ ] scumbag no i liked him he's
always been nice great guy yeah [ __ ] you
yeah i don't like this guy he's always
been nice bruce willis spoke at it
what is this what's up
lady gaga used to come in because she
did an album
when tony bennett and uh billy joel put
the album together yeah they used to
like bring us to good morning america to
be like they'd be like we have the kids
from frank sinatra and then we just dip
out and go smoke weed in central park
we were jaded by that [ __ ] by the time
we graduated it was cool
wow yeah we got to do some really cool
[ __ ] um how much of these kids you think
those opportunities in their life well
that's what the cool thing was like i'm
sure you feel this in a way i don't know
what made you see the city but like i
lived so far out i never came to
manhattan yeah and i like my school was
in long island city and that's where i
like met like my closest friends my best
friends from washington heights he
he went to remember that school bard
like early college remembers that school
where was that it was in the city lower
east side but it was like connected to
bard college
or it was a high school like a prime
school but yeah you could like take some
college classes did you you scored good
on that test yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then you graduated i did a good
audition
i still can't read but i didn't ask my
[ __ ] ass no no school shootings at
art school though yeah i mean they don't
even
look like hamilton if they try to do it
both sides yes but this one's full of
shooters
did you have something we had 125 kids
per grade it was sick
yeah that's a good number yeah
i went to a smaller school like that
baruch
oh okay
public school that's the public yeah
yeah yeah yeah the college it's
connected to the college it was inside
it but we didn't have the same ability
oh my school was connected to devry
university
and these dudes that went to devry would
just be hollering at our girls and we
would have to scrap the fry guys it was
nuts dude it was crazy oh cause i'm sure
there was just like some empty rooms and
they rented it out from
we were in a business building we were
like two floors above yeah because the
school wasn't finished the school's in
astoria now and it's beautiful and i i'm
pissed because i tried to do my special
there and the the school said yes the
board of education shut me down
that's wild it's like i did everything i
was supposed to do
i came back here with judd apatow and
they're like the board of education i
made those [ __ ] sign an nda
and gave them my set and they're like
they're you say triggering things for
children and we can't have you it was
just like
i don't know they didn't give me an
example they just i'm about halfway
through it so far i don't know what
could none of it seems triggering
they wouldn't let me do it man that bung
me hard because it's a beautiful day
that school is beautiful now stunning
they had they they
did it completely it wasn't built when i
was going
they have an orchestra pit it's a public
school
that's like funded through like people
and whatnot it's so sick if your school
had to fight owl school who do you think
will win um
well if asked i'll school fought back
it's a hate crime so yeah
that's true that's true if there's no
such thing as hate crimes yeah
al took the toughest gays from his
school and he fought bro there's there's
some tough tough gay guys in my school
yeah yeah
yeah well the guys at al school have to
admit to being gay and that's true
yeah who do you think wins in that fight
straight up street fight old school new
york
grab a snapple bottle i don't know
enough about his school to say that but
i mean i know a few kids that can scrap
i think he said your school's [ __ ] yeah
he said you guys i think he said in the
nicest way yeah he said you guys
does that come from art school say what
tupac came from our school there's some
gangsters that become michael j went to
laguardia that's true that's true that's
true but yeah we'll still [ __ ] them up
no question i'm just saying far rock
yeah but he but he came into the city
for school like
oh
like even every school had [ __ ] yeah
now my school [ __ ] y'all up
brooklyn attack was kind of wild yeah
there was like latin kings in it yeah
yeah yeah yeah tech in that yeah yeah
because tech was the one who was like
the dumbest of the smart ones
right
then bronx science and then brooklyn
tech wasn't that regis too
this is the [ __ ] that we took every year
no regis i thought there was a school
like uh isn't that like a jewish school
i don't know i don't know
my kid's going private [ __ ] the borders
are you really putting your kid in he's
in private school how would you get
three three yeah and he's in private at
that age bro he's in a private school
but are you going to keep them in high
school
they don't have public school at three
they don't they don't let poor people
educate their children until later in
the life
bro you came in here today saying you
got your kid in the best school yeah
he's three though yeah
i went to school
dude you didn't go to school until you
were seven yeah
[Laughter]
you never went to school
no but you're not going public bro
[Music]
you get so many experiences cultural
experiences diversity what are you
talking about like my whole friend group
my comfort with different cultures
my kids last name is velez they needed
one of them
yeah native american and if you don't
think this kid is going to the most
exclusive [ __ ]
private school boarding school wherever
he's living at that time my daughter and
that's why everybody's like don't you
watch your kid don't know that my
daughter be hanging around with these
minorities
[Laughter]
no but my son's going to public school
100 what experience did you get a post
when you can't get a private school in
new york uh no it's not the same when we
were kids hanging out with black people
and not making an absolute fool of
myself
like my private school kids just had no
clue how to do it like no clue just how
to be around people that weren't like
rich white kids
they just didn't understand how to do it
and like it was just embarrassing seeing
it happen and then but i was just i just
went to school with all these different
kids so it was just super normal it was
just what we expected almost to the
point where if i was just with like all
white people i felt like the outsider
because there's certain jokes that i
would like want to make but they just
wouldn't get it
and or just like ribbing and that kind
of stuff that they just wouldn't kind of
understand so that experience i'm like
that's [ __ ]
invaluable man my brothers went private
really mm-hmm
we have catholic schools
catholic school is not private yeah it
is you pay for it you pay for it but it
ain't the same as private it's poor
[ __ ] in catholic school too
yeah us but like
but you know what i'm saying like if you
took us out of where we were going to be
i was supposed to go to melbourne van
buren oh yeah so it's like i didn't have
to go there because i was able to get
into this school and then on top of it
my older brother my older brother and
younger brother had to go to uh
catholics so they didn't have to end up
in van buren
dude my boy's dad was the principal of
martin van buren and he used to scrap
kids on the regular yeah yes kids would
fight him
see that's lit i don't want my kid going
to a [ __ ] up public school well dude
you don't have the choice anymore it's
not set up like it used to be
you get to choose three schools you want
to go to and you might get it's like a
lottery oh back in the day used to be
like your neighborhood no no there's no
zone schools no more what
yes
you know show's post kid
is it's a matter of like
you're you're in a zone so you're like
even if you live down the block from a
school you're not promised to go to that
because when we were growing up it was
if you lived in this neighborhood you
had access to all these schools and when
you're in elementary you could pretty
much go to whatever one and then middle
school you had to like i had to lie
about my address to go to a nicer school
yeah you used like your dad's work
address yeah yeah some [ __ ] like that
and uh but then in middle school you had
to like
like not audition but you basically
submit your report cards and [ __ ] and
then high school it was the same thing
and it got a little bit harder and
harder to get to but if you had good
grades like you could go to like a
really good public school and there'd
still be like diversity like economic
diversity with some rich [ __ ]
with some poor [ __ ] but at
least you're with like the real world
that's my fear about private school with
my kid is there's no doubt the education
will be better in terms of the book
learning but how do i get him to
understand like life
yeah but at the same time dude he'll be
like shaking hands with like politicians
kids and uh hanging out with like that's
the people that will put him in position
to be i know what he's saying i'm gonna
put him in position to be great i don't
need him to be friends with politicians
it takes
a village
[Laughter]
you understand what i'm saying like
there are certain things that we were
able to do you get that in new york city
dude look at you you're fine no no these
private school kids all went to [ __ ]
like riverdale like horace mann and
these like schools that like you're
basically living on a college campus is
different yeah not my kids that's not my
kid's private school so yeah it's
different and also sports like
it's trash they're trash at sports no
tennis
[Laughter]
get out of here tennis
okay
every sport they play in public school
you can either be knocked unconscious or
yeah
no i do think that there's value i do
think there's value to that experience
like in the same way you come into that
school it's like you're hanging out with
all these like white kids and [ __ ] like
that and you're going to school with
them and now all of a sudden you're
comfortable you both need exposure you
need exercise
i need you too yeah but like and you
even i never came to manhattan if i did
it was like a thing like so like now
like
back then like my best friend was from
washington heights so we would just come
to the city all the time and it was just
i had never done that i just stayed in
my neighborhood rode around on my bike
and that was it i feel like yeah i feel
like getting those moments and like
getting that exposure is super valuable
like because i'll see white dudes that
don't hang out with like black dudes at
all for example and like their default
personality around black dudes is like
look how awkward white people is so i'm
an awkward white guy yeah and they just
become this character of what they think
black people see them as yeah and it's
embarrassing bro it makes it harder for
everyone everybody it's like the black
people don't like it i'm assuming
because they know what you're doing do
you feel that way yeah all the time yeah
i always found it very insulting like
you'd be very insulting to your
intelligence so either that or you get
the over the top like yo my brother my
brother this yeah i voted for obama
[Laughter]
i did that all the time so i just i
don't want my kids to have to have that
and it's so easy
you just have to send them to a shittier
school
right that is the question
you just got to give him like one or two
years
at the what at a bad school yeah yeah
give him a couple years at elementary
learn how to make friends learn how to
talk to everybody and then i'll send you
to the good [ __ ] that sounds fair
um yeah now you're coming to the good
school with like puerto rican game like
you've been around the puerto ricans who
are 14 years old harassing girls on the
subway and then you take that [ __ ] up to
[ __ ] riverdale and no one's stopping
you oh
they'll kick your ass
stop talking to your teacher like that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you